I want talk about something we've been
doing on the show lately it was an idea
we started doing this we were inspired
by something on Animal Planet called the
Puppy Bowl and people really loved the
Puppy Bowl and we thought let's get in
on this we should do it too so we
started doing it on this show and it's
becoming a huge hit very popular
so here tonight enjoy another
installment of Puppy Conan
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
there's puffy Andy and like the real
Andy he's high as a kite be Conan of
course looking around surveying the
audience he's about as depressed as I am
most the time and here's tonight's
special guest on puppy Conan puppy
Shaquille O'Neal let's go
[Applause]
let me check
USAC took a real interest in and andy
there for a second
puppy Conan's still depressed
[Applause]
but exactly captures how I feel all the
time
and tonight puppy Conan is introducing a
new program this is a new program we're
very excited about it please welcome
hamster Conan we're very excited about
[Applause]
there's hamster Andy
mr. Conan I don't know what's with my
hair my hair proportionally is 2/3 of my
body look Youssef outright hamster ande
is just there he is ok he's he said now
there's where we are making out again
and and of course hamster Conan's
special guest tonight this is a real
treat he's a music legend Prince hamster
Prince it doesn't get better than that
what a terrific show
[Applause]
ladies and gentlemen let's go over here
and join the fun I love these dogs these
are great we're gonna tell you who's on
the show tonight I am delighted
absolutely delighted because tonight we
have is an accomplished actor Owen first
let me sit down hold on
there's pooping going on on hamster
Conan
oh good not here good looking around I
was like why did you tell me that before
hands are gonna cheer up depressed puppy
Conan all weepy when look at what Shaq
feels like he's being ignored stack
hates this Joe Jack's wondering why he's
wearing a Lakers Joe yeah
it was like three teens you know that
was a while ago Jack what's wrong with
you anyway it's just stupid